hello people I'd like to welcome you to
the first uh Communications Forum event
of this semester I'm David thorburn
professor of literature and the director
of the MIT Communications Forum I'm very
happy to see you here uh and I would
like to make a couple of quick
announcements one is uh if you look on
the on the screen you'll see projected
there our ven our our uh for Forum
projects for the fall term I hope most
of you will be able to attend them uh
uh Fuller descriptions of each event are
available if you click around on the
website I also would like to make a a
particular announcement about the Forum
that is scheduled for Thursday October
4th it's the next forum uh on collective
intelligence what we're hoping for is a
general very wide ranging discussion on
the wisdom of collective intelligence
but also on the limitations of some
aspects of collective intelligence and
in addition to the two speakers already
listed there one from the Harvard
Business School kareim Lani and one from
from the Sloan school here at MIT Tom
Malone uh there's a third speaker uh who
isn't yet listed on our on our materials
but will be I mention him especially
because we're in his shop now it's uh
Alex pentlin from the media lab will
join in that conversation on October 4th
and I hope many of you will be able to
uh attend that uh it's my happy Duty now
to introduce this forum the first of a
series of forums uh uh under the
collective wisdom of the uh under the
collaborative uh uh wisdom and
Arrangements of the MIT media lab and
the comparative media studies program
the communications forum is very uh
pleased and and uh excited to be a small
collaborator in what promises to be a
very interesting and Rich and ongoing
project that CMS and the the the media
lab have uh worked out uh uh W with the
help of a very generous Grant from the
Knight Foundation uh my understanding is
that this first uh uh session will be
devoted to broadly to definition uh and
then in addition to a second event in
this series this fall there will be
continue we will continue uh over the
next few semesters to to to follow
through on this theme All That Remains
for me to do then uh is first to remind
all of you that the format of our forums
is fairly standard and I want I and I
hope you'll uh help us with them uh as
in most forums the speakers talk for
about an hour sharing this sharing the
space together for an hour and that and
the second hour is given over to
question and answer uh session with with
our audience M My Hope Is that you'll be
as Lively and as passionate and as
critical if you choose to be uh as many
of our previous audiences have been
I let me remind you that we are being
recorded that your your uh question will
will go out in The Ether and will be
preserved in audio and video formats
presumably Forever on uh the website
when you rise to ask your questions it
would be very helpful if you would
identify yourself for the speakers and
for
posterity my final uh uh obligation here
is to introduce uh the moderator of uh
uh of tonight's session my friend and
colleague Henry Jenkins he's the Peter
deflores professor of humanities at MIT
the founding director of the MIT
comparative media studies program the
author of more books than most people
can count most recently a book a
remarkable and and very apparently
continuingly influential book on
convergence
culture uh Henry Jenkins thank you
so uh as a way of launching the center
uh Chris chick me ha and I are going to
sort of lay out our own takes on what we
mean by Civic media as part of this new
center from the future on future Civic
media and then turn it over to our
esteemed guests to share some of their
experiences and Reflections on this
category um as I be I apologize to those
listening to podcast because this is
going to be very image intensive
presentation but bear with me as I I'll
try to describe at least some of the
images we're looking at as we go for
those who may listen to this later um
the here on the screen are two images
and I sort of instinctively I think you
see the one of them the black and white
image as one that embodies Civic
engagement here's a classic image of a
group of men reading newspapers on a
street corner engaged in dialogue about
serious National issues
the second one may be much more
debatable right it's a group of young
Japanese women uh taking photographs
with cell phone cameras with traditional
cameras we don't know what they're
taking a photograph of and it's sort of
thing I think it's very interesting
first of all to think about the gender
dimensions of that does the fact that
their young women change the way we
regard their activity so who was engaged
in this activity somewhat shapes our
judgment about whether it's Civic or not
our assumptions about what they're
photographing matter so if I said this
was a political Rally or a circus parade
or a celebrity getting out of an
automobile we might respond to that
image of them taking the picture rather
differently depending on what it was we
imagine the content or context of it is
similarly whether we imagin them
connecting the photographs they were
taking back to some larger communal site
would affect the way we perceive this
this activity so the question is is this
Civic media what constitutes Civic media
for for me the definition I'm working
from is one that says Civic media is any
use of any medium which Fosters Civic
engagement it's intentionally an
extraordinarily broad definition it's
intended to be broader than the phrase
citizen media which would Define a a
narrower subset or citizen journalism
but includes both of those within its
perview but the point is that there the
use of the technology is as important as
the technology itself self in
determining whether something
constitutes Civic Media or not it's what
we do with the technology certainly the
affordances of the technology make it
easier or harder for us to use it for
civic activity but what the techn how we
use it is also very much part of that
proposition and I'm sort of relying on
the definition of medium that Lisa Gman
has proposed which says a medium is a
communication technology and the social
protocols that grow up around its use
and those two things together help
determine what we mean by a Civic media
so the question I've of I've been
thinking about a lot lately is what does
democracy look like what's the image
Bank by which we represent democracy and
very often the images we have are those
of the colonial American Experience the
revolution the signing of the
Declaration Boston TB the Spirit of 76
we might update that to sometime in the
1930s and here's another whole image
Bank of democ what democracy looks like
that was consciously constructed by the
popular front during the 1930s so we
have kapper movies we have Norman
Rockwell we we talk about Aaron copelan
maybe Fanfare for the common man might
be what democracy sounds like uh but
what's striking is when we get to
contemporary representations of
democracy they're almost always retro so
one of the sort of challenging things
about a center for the future Civic
media is to imagine democracy itself
having a future to reinvent the set of
images we have for thinking about what
we mean by Civic engagement so that
across the right and the left what we
see is a return in the imagery we use to
talk about democracy to either colonial
America or 1930s but rarely the present
and almost never the future so we are as
a center are trying to encourage people
to think creatively about what democracy
looks like now and what democracy will
look like in the
future now one classic account of this
challenge of Civic engagement is Robert
putnam's bowling alone and those of you
who read the book know that his Vivid
image of Civic engagement his nostal his
retro image of democracy is the image of
a 1950s bowling leak where people
gathered for a shared activity
conversations took place around it some
of them were publicly minded some of
them were personal gossip but the
community felt a commitment to each
other that was reaffirmed each time some
somset of it gathered together at the
bowling alley to to engage in
this now his contrast to that is
television in which he argues that
television has made us less Civic less
engaged and I think he's wrong about
this in two different dimensions he
collapses together two arguments one is
the privatization argument that we're
more likely to stay at home and
consuming television which is an
argument about the technology and then
he tends to read television as valuing
entertainment over news and assuming
that entertainment can't be the basis
for civic engagement so first of all
this these images from the 1950s suggest
that in the context of 50s American
culture for variety of reasons
television may have been used in a more
social way because there were fewer sets
because people GA mythically gathered in
people's living rooms the Civic culture
engaged with television in a different
way than we engage with it today so we
can't just look at the technology and
determine what its properties are we
also have to think about this history of
its use the structures in which we
engage with this technology but secondly
if his example of Civic engagement is
the bowling league it's surely not the
news value of bowling that determined
that Civic activity or Civic engagement
took place around it Recreation you know
you know Recreation recreational
activities can be the basis of Civic
engagement it's what takes place around
them again that I think determines the
ultimate impact they might have we may
be this these images I thought are kind
of interesting to think about what
television means today as we move toward
large screen televisions home
entertainment complexes and one of the
things that interested me these I looked
up ultimate entertainment center on the
web and these are some of the images I
found but what's interesting is they all
contain more seats than this nuclear
family the ideal entertainment complex
that's being presented to us today is
one that does include inviting friends
and neighbors over to enjoy the
properties of the meum whether we
actually do it or not is interesting but
the Technologies are being designed for
social use again rather than purely for
individualized use and I think that's an
interesting historical phenomenon so if
we go if this is our image of Civic
engagement then what do we make of this
this is this is World of Warcraft right
this is a group of people gathered
together in a guild structure to get
their photographs taken or a virtual
photograph taken to represent the social
ties that exist between the members of
this community so whatever they're doing
they're not bowling alone now whether it
fully constitutes the bowling league
that putam romanticizes or not as open
to discussion but in a sense that
there's a kind of naasan Civic
engagement that could be seen as we look
at these new kinds of social structures
that are emerge on the web the problem
is these are now communities of Interest
not the local communities it's no longer
a face-to-face contact in the space
these people may be all over the planet
but they may feel a very strong sense of
social obligation to each other Which
shapes their
behavior again I I'm in as I was getting
this ready I was just intrigued by the
images how media are used to create
Community to connect people together and
another person who wrote about this very
persuasively is Benedict Anderson who
talks about the notion
of an imagined community that is the
degree to which Civic media in the past
and his example in this case was the
London Times fostered a sense of shared
identity which was Central to allowing
the members of the British Empire at
least those empowered members of the
British Empire to feel a sense of social
connection to each other and our images
of newspaper which could have been
represented as a solitary medium
frequently involve groups of people
engag in conversations with each other
across those various medium now what he
tell tells us is that these are imagined
communities in the sense that we very
few of us will meet none of us will meet
every member of the nation let alone the
members of the British Empire It's a
larger social organization that is going
to be reinforced by face-to-face
communication even what the nation means
is constantly in the dispute and I have
here a variety of images contemporary
images of America or patriotism and
conflicting claims about what it is to
be an American but that sense of being
an American or that sense of being a
Bostonian uh that's embedded in then
going to being part of the Red Sox
Nation uh sort of is a kind of civic
identity that is the beginnings and and
both putnam's account and in in
Anderson's account of a sense of social
connection or social obligation to each
other it is part of what we mean when we
talk about civic identity this could be
fostered through social networks these
are some traditional images of social
networks Rockwell's picture from the
1950s a more contemporary and playful
revoking of it which says we're not
gossiping we're Network working but
gossip became a vehicle in women's
culture historically by which people
exchanged values made judgments felt a
sense of social connection to each other
now again the challenge is we're moving
as a country toward diasporic
experiences of the community the local
very important part of these traditional
no communities is maybe disintegrating
but an expanded sense of the local is
part of what we experience this is an
image of the diaspora created by Katrina
by a particular disaster as people from
New Orleans has spread across the
country but if we talk to students at
MIT many of them reads local newspapers
from their hometowns many of them are
listening to web-based radio cast from
the place they came from our sense of an
expanded local as that interacts with
the physical local becomes very much
part of this and it's again about
imagined community that can form the
basis for other kinds of Civic
engagement as is these are images of
Technologies again to make the point of
the move some IND Technologies which can
be individualized in some use can be
collective in other use and I love this
image of the phonograph as it becomes a
shared media experience and the way that
looks forward to things like iPod and
zoom commercials which talk about
beaming music between people as a kind
of social practice we can think about
different ways Technologies enable these
kinds of Civic engagement uh from Second
Life which spend a lot of effort
building an online community to
augmented reality games which are
designed to foster a greater sense of
Engagement with the physical iCal world
around them you know this idea of
communities of Interest as they relate
to the local is scarcely new that if we
go back to the coffee houses which were
romanticized and hass's notion of the
public sphere it turns out many of them
were themed there were literary half
coffee houses there were political
coffee houses so they were both
communities of interest and local
communities that manifest themselves
through people gathering together to
engage in communitive practices side by
side and the modern notion of the Meetup
functions in much that same way to be
both a virtual community online and a
physical Community face to face both
physically local and virtually local at
the same time and Define through a
variety of communities of Interest this
the Minneapolis role players meet up in
the bottom image
there is flicker a Civic in media in the
sense that we're talking about is Flickr
a local media Jee Burgess a researcher
in Australia has done work on the ways
in which flicker encouraged at least in
her work encouraged people to find each
other by geographic location since you
take pictures of specific locations and
those are identified as such on Flickr
people in in Queensland began to gather
on Sundays to take picture of shared
locations they did meetups they began to
focus their cameras on their own cities
they began to see their cities in New
Light and that led to certain kinds of
Civic activism for this group of people
so the fact it was a virtual Network did
not prevent it from simultaneously being
something that was very involved at the
local level and we can imagine that
passing it self off to Google Maps and
Wikipedia and other kinds of projects
which use media that are broad-based
networked media to think about the local
through new lenses YouTube is becoming
an important site for local activism
even as it becomes a national network
and we can think about the publicity
this week over the tasering of the
student it's a recurring theme that
YouTube has helped to identify and bring
to National spotline that coexist with
stories like the one in the tech this
week about why or actually was USA Today
this morning was about why Lo campus
police are being pressured to be more
forceful in their relation to their
students in the wake of Virginia Tech so
there's a debate being had that's both
national and local that uses YouTube
this is a Machinima film made about the
student movement in France one of the
first things when the movie games came
out it was immediately turned to exper
students used it to medium to explain
within their own local community what
was going on and used the web as a
distribution point to explain to more
people what's going on now we might not
ordinarily think of action figures as a
Civic media but this is a RI a protest
that was in Singapore a few weeks ago
where there are some restrictions on
public Gatherings and the way they they
signified support was to let people
assemble action figures with signs in a
public space rather than the physical
bodies of people who could be disrupted
and the police still came and broke it
up claiming this was a public gathering
of action figures apparently so so the
point is that the action figure is not
intrinsically a Civic medium but the
ways in which it was used was used to
express Civic concerns and was became a
vehicle for shared experiences so who
are CI Who's involved with Civic media
as we began the project we've been
interested in a number of groups that we
think have potential to be part of it
clearly the blogging Community is an
important group right now the citizen
journalist is an important force and
redefining microl local news local news
national news so forth but also the
higho journalist this is the classic
image of the high school journalist this
is much more what the high school
journalist looks like today but in some
communities which have lost their local
papers we're very interested in what
would happen if we trained High School
journalists to play more of a role in
reporting beyond the school and becoming
part of the Civic infrastructure for a
particular Town we're interested in the
ethnic news and Ellen Hume uh spoke to
us our research Group LA yesterday to
talk about the important increasing role
of of ethnic ources both print and
online in a community like Boston
they've mapped something like 80
different ethnic Publications in Boston
that play very important roles for those
communities and transgenerational
communication becomes important so in
this case I'm not suggesting the car is
a medium although Marshall mcluen would
have but I I'm suggesting that this is a
shared activity at least a romanticized
image of a shared activity of a
grandfather a father and son working on
a car there's no reason why that
couldn't be a computer and a website
or live journal page or a Facebook page
a shared activity that's digital and and
Jee Burgess again in Australia has
written about uh digital storytelling
groups in much this way where people
share knowledge across Generations can
become the basis of Civic media what
historically democracy was kept Alive by
micro rituals local rituals whether it's
Town pageants whether it's state fairs
whether it's communal picnics became the
ways in which people reaffirmed their
connection to that face to-face
community so as we think about the
future of Civic media we need to figure
out what those social rituals are and
how we create new social rituals that
bring people together in powerful ways
to enhance Civic engagement the
challenge is to sort of move us from a
culture where democracy is a special
event bound up in the election that curs
every two to four years to move it
toward a lifestyle that we engage with
on a day-to-day basis that is as part
much part of our life as popular culture
where it's not about one decision but
many decision decisions that reaffirm
our connections to the community and
this is not a new challenge it's an old
one as this image from the 1930s
suggests that I sort of self-consciously
I'm going back to those retro images at
the end that suggests that from the very
beginning what democracy was what
citizenship was was seen as a challenge
something that had to be renewed again
and again not something we simply had
but something we created and so the
question is what are the Technologies
today that will create the sense of
democratic participation and Civ
engagement with that in mind I'm going
to turn it over to my colleague Chris
chick me high here at the media lab who
is who is are one of my partners in
crime in the new MIT Center for future
Civic
media thank you Henry and uh I think
you'll see that there's uh areas of uh
strong overlap between uh how Henry and
I conceive this and I I should also um
uh mention that there's a a third person
in the equation uh Professor Mitchell
Resnik who uh I see his C hair back
there uh uh is in the audience and um uh
he he isn't joining us today but I'll
try to show a little bit of his work
later um we I I wanted to talk a little
bit about some of the logistics about
what the center is going to be doing um
uh and to uh actually just start by um
uh thanking uh Jack knight uh for
starting the Knight Foundation who have
given us a uh an initial $5 million uh
Grant to to start the center um the
Knight Foundation of course uh comes
from uh Jack the night brothers and uh
by extension night Ritter newspapers
which was a uh an interesting kind of
model for how to run newspapers it was a
a wire service that at least I grew up
seeing night Ritter head you know uh uh
Runners at the beginning of an article
um and but what was interesting about
night Ritter was it was really a
Consortium of many smaller papers local
papers uh from Minneapolis from Miami
from San Jose and what these papers
realized they had to do in kind of the
New Media culture and and uh a Ross
press and AP and all these other wire
Services was uh kind of work together
essentially um to take their best
journalist send them to Washington to
the Washington Bureau send them to
Europe to cover uh events and then bring
people back and um uh but the the
commitment was always to those local
papers they always said we need to
circulate our journalists back so that
they can remember the community that
they came from um uh it's a kind of a uh
an interesting process and if anyone's
seen um uh
uh uh what's happened to night Ritter in
in fact they essentially went bankrupt
um a few years ago were bought out by a
couple of companies including one called
mcache um uh and mcache has kind of
continued some of this Approach at least
in their Washington Bureau one of the
reasons that's very interesting that uh
um uh Bill Moyers for instance talked
about in his recent uh show selling the
War uh part of the bill Moyer's Journal
was that in fact mcache journalists were
predicting what was happening with the
Iraq War what was happening with wmd
very well so well in fact that the local
papers were no longer buying their
stories which I find absolutely
fascinating that you can you know have
journalism so good that there's no
market for it um and in fact you know
that's that's a little bit of uh what's
been uh pushing uh the KN Foundation to
get into this uh arena is that they they
typically have done a lot of their
funding uh funding of journalists and um
uh they uh you know in informal
conversations I've gotten the sense that
that they love the idea that they're
training the best kind of journalists
around that they're uh funding really
great journalism programs around the
country but the opportunities for those
journalists to practice the kind of
independent journalism uh uh the kind of
uh Free Press uh away from uh large kind
of uh corporate Megapolis uh media
consortiums has just declined and so
it's it's very difficult actually now
for a good journalist to even find a job
and so the KN Foundation created this uh
KN challenge which is a grant which
they're actually in their second run
right now people should take a look
because they're giving grants as small
as a couple uh you know tens of
thousands of dollars up to very large
kind of leadership grants um but uh but
their point was that they want to take a
look and kind of game what's happening
next in the in the roles of New Media
technology and the way that people think
about and report news um and so we
applied and uh received a leadership
Grant and part of the component of what
that means is that all the other KN
Foundation uh grant winners are going to
be coming to campus this spring spring
and every spring for at least a few more
years uh to kind of show their work in a
in a large kind of conference format to
interface with each other but also
people are interested so uh we'll
probably be announcing dates for that
event in the spring sometime soon so if
you're interested in this you'll get to
meet a lot of very interesting people uh
somewhere between where uh Community uh
uh journalism and uh computation meet um
uh so that's my little introduction
about uh what what uh where our funding
came from and what the uh influence
towards our doing this was um I just
want to say that you know our our our
goal is essentially to develop new
technologies and social systems as Henry
described um and we come from very
different backgrounds CMS and the media
lab have been uh neighbors have
collaborated uh for about 20 years but
um you know we really come from
different backgrounds on some level and
the media lab is always thinking through
problems uh from a technological
standpoint so um if I can take another
six minutes or so um I'll try to descri
describe a little bit about what uh that
process has been for my research in my
group um uh and that's simply um that uh
uh you know Henry gave the example of of
the different modes of use of Television
um describing the process of uh uh still
in in Rural and uh developing nations
watching television is an activity that
a village does um even though in the
United States uh you know the the
majority of people watch television
alone or with their nuclear family um
and so so uh you know what what I I feel
is that um uh uh I could take a a
television out to my block in Somerville
um and encourage people to watch it with
me out on the street um and you know two
things would happen one my television's
smaller than any of my neighbors so no
one would watch second uh you know the
property values would go down um so uh
so you know what's interesting is that
uh the use of technology is not just
about a device uh when we say technology
we often can be referring to an entire
you know tradition of of technical
development or we can be referring to a
device and so you have to get a little
bit specific when you talk about this
the device of the television doesn't
prescribe who can use it other than you
know at what point it becomes too small
because you're in too large a room with
too many people um but it's of course uh
it's of course a device and a a set of
Social and cultural constraints of how
that device can be used um you know and
so if I take the television out to the
street no one will watch it with me in
all honesty or they'll spend more time
watching me than the television but you
know an interesting coraly of that is
the fact that um technology get used in
uh really uh strange and and and unusual
ways in other places let me um bring an
example of this kind of device and what
this device means um uh Brun lur talks
about technology uh French theorist
talks about technology as Society made
durable um in other words devices and uh
and the culture of their use are
co-produced and thus technology and
their effects on culture are also
co-produced and so his point is that
technology is in a sense an reification
of Society um and he gives an example in
a kind of a long metaphor of uh one of
these door closers um uh I I use this
example all the time but I still don't
know what they're really called um but
these automatic door closers and so uh
you know in the luran analogy you you
might work in an open plan office like
an architecture office and you have a
small desk and uh in the summertime uh
people keep leaving the door open and
you get very hot uh you know it's hot
outside and um you're very uncomfortable
So eventually you you what everyone does
which is put a little sign up on the
door that says please close the door
after yourself and of course we all know
those signs never work um uh so you've
you've tried to inform people uh as to
uh you know how they can help you but in
fact uh information doesn't lead to
action so then you go to your manager
and you say well I'm really hot all the
time can you buy one of those door
thingies that I can never remember what
they're called but can you buy one of
those to close the door so that I'm not
as hot in the summer and the manager
says oh no you know that that's way over
budget um can't do that and so you uh
you know maybe you work worse and you
you know short your your your keyboard
short circuits because we were sweat and
uh eventually the manager decides it's
cost- effective to put one of those
things in he calls the janitor guy the
janitor Kai comes puts it up with his
you know expert technical knowledge and
you know the door now closes
automatically um you know so you're
you're much more comfortable but there's
someone else on the other end of that
open plan office who's right under the
air conditioning vent and he loved it
when the door was open because of course
that was the only time that he felt
comfortable
um so now he's cold all summer and Lor's
point is that even this very benal
simple example is an example of how
Technologies are inherently political
devices what they do is they allow the
world to become a little bit easier for
one person or one set of people um uh
and at the same time uh uh you know they
might or might not make it more
difficult to maneuver for a set of other
people um so one of the things that uh
you know my group has been doing
research on is the idea that if the unit
of consumption is the individual as it
is for almost all contemporary consumer
electronics um then the device is
probably going to better the situation
of that individual um and that's a you
know it's a very important principle and
um an example is a I'll give an example
of a project that one of my students did
um uh which was her noticing could we
have volume up on this laptop uh her
noticing that cell phones were making
people okay interesting we're getting an
echo too not that's from uh Technologies
were making people kind of selfish cell
phones are making people speak very
rudely or talk during lectures so she
came up with a simple piece of jewelry
that when you press the button on it
disconnects any cell phone within about
3 meters um and so she can essentially
create this bubble where loud rude
conversations don't have to happen
around her um and this is a great
example of in fact what all Technologies
are mostly doing um and and it's absurd
uh in the sense that that uh you know uh
it it it can and should be illegal um uh
but uh but it's also um it's also a
strange situation where huh interesting
getting a very loud Echo um uh but it's
also um uh it's also uh uh shows that in
fact you can never lose money selling a
product that will Empower an individual
but often it comes at the at the expense
of a community of of public space or of
groups um so Society is a long way from
neutral and uh society's durable goods
are thus a long way from neutral as well
um some people have more power some
people can express themselves more than
others uh and Technologies kind of rify
or instantiate that on sub level um uh
and unfortunately the people who
typically design Technologies are
serving themselves on some level so uh
uh uh the and the mechanisms by which
the Technologies get distributed uh
essentially uh reproduce the iniquity by
which they're uh produced so when you
hear someone saying that a technology is
neutral um and they can be used for good
and bad which I hear every few days
walking through the campuses of MIT um
understand what they've done is they've
they've zoomed out of the situation to
the point where everything looks like a
tiny Speck everyone looks like ants and
it doesn't really matter anymore um
whenever I hear someone say the
technology is neutral I reach for my gun
analogy um uh which you know which is
that uh and I borrow this from johanes
shod an STS theorist who says that you
know it's possible to kill someone with
a a toothbrush uh if you're really
creative and it's also possible to kill
someone with a gun but of course um
that's that's a really stupid way of
looking at it because guns make it much
easier to kill people and cleaning your
teeth with a toothbrush is is much
better for your health so um so so
Technologies are only neutral when
you've zoomed out to the point where it
doesn't really matter um so if if in
fact uh there is this kind of lack of
neutrality in the way the Technologies
are produced distributed and the modes
of their uh you know received youth use
then it's possible to imagine that a
society where most Technologies are
designed for the individual to empower
the individual is one where a lot of the
technologies that come out will actually
in many cases not benefit Civil Society
um so uh you know so so as we go along
and we think of that Somerville
television example one of the
interesting cor laries of that is that
when a technology goes somewhere where
those same uh social and cultural Moors
don't exist you get really interesting
reuses and you know in this case I'm
thinking of Trinidadian steel drums
Trinidad where uh a net importer of
chemicals had all of these extra drums
and figured out this beautiful way of
making music with them and you see that
again and again in you know in
Technologies of the in in cultures that
are on the technological margin um and
it's a really interesting corollary to
the fact that we have those same things
we just don't use them as well um uh
because we have received modes of use um
so uh you know one one of the
interesting thing ways that this works
is that Technologies develop our sense
of self and they develop our sense of
what's possible um a melon scoop for
instance that I grew up with uh suggests
that in in a good household you serve
your guest melons and discreet bitable
chunks um I and and and they're very
powerful and you know suggesting that I
myself have succumbed to their magic um
likewise the ex existence of automobiles
facilitates C suburban and exurban
living um you know uh spreads us out on
some level um and these are only the
articulated intended behaviors of these
Technologies philosophers technology
Andrew fenberg talks about the all the
things that technology do that aren't
part of their intended effects secondary
effects um you know so uh nearly all
American Technologies for instance
assume and thus consume cheap energy uh
you buy a leaf blower to clean your lawn
not to put a hole in the ozone layer to
wake up your neighbor but actually a
leaf blower does all three of those
things quite well you if you wanted to
wake up your neighbor you would probably
want to use a leaf blower so so the
point is that their secondary unintended
effects function equally well um and
they're they're really a part of what
the technology is at a central level not
just as a kind of a side effect or a
unintended consequence of them um and
many of the assumed unintended
consequences or side effects of those
Technologies are ones that are built in
to facilitate an individual consumer an
individual uh kind of you know
libertarian unit of society so what does
this have to do with CI civil uh Civic
media it's simply this that it's much
easier to produce a device and sell it
if you can sell it to every consumer at
a one:1 ratio like an iPod then if you
develop it as a public transportation
system uh where you need to uh uh get a
particular you know city or country
behind you um and I'd argue that it
isn't a coincidence that we consume
media alone in a society so far along
the path of kind of commercialization to
individuals um uh you know and what
happens as that happens is that these
these Technologies on a certain level
turn us all into competitors with each
other you know so an example that comes
very easily to mind is the Hummer
um this is uh from a website called F2
where people uh use Democratic
participatory media to show themselves
flipping the bird at Hummers um but the
point of a Hummer is that you know it's
it's the it's it's considered a safe
techn you know a safe car SUVs are safe
cars people talk about them in those
terms when in fact they're dangerous for
the planet they're dangerous for
individuals they're dangerous for our
society it's a great kind of you know
Nexus of where these conflicting
interests kind of point out um you know
I drive a beat up Jetta and it does on a
global level exactly what a Hummer does
at a local level um uh and I happen to
know that no Chomsky is tooling around
in an A4 very heavy aie um so you know
what are our choices well the choice is
uh public transportation right but um
but public transportation is a unit of
Technology that's consumed by
communities that's consumed by cities or
countries um most of what we have are
made to be consumed by an individual and
so as long as we're kind of stuck in
that we run the risk of developing these
technologies that aren't actually useful
for communities or for civic engagement
um so Civic Media Tech you know Civic
media and Civic media Technologies are
ones that don't treat the world as a
zero sum game uh a government you know
doesn't lose power if it releases
information uh a community that has open
and Creative Commons whether it's online
Commons or common spaces as a useful
thing and I think that one of the tricks
as we as we start the center is to
reimagine not just technology that
increases Civic engagement um but but
actually increases a particular kind of
Civic engagement that we we we would
like to promote and that's certainly
possible um you know I'll just finally
you know Henry was mentioning putam so I
was thinking about putam I was thinking
this really interesting example of
thinking about if we could have the
audio on the laptop up again um uh uh if
we think about Civic media uh or if we
think about social capital um putam has
this very uh you know boy audio on the
laptop please um putam has this thanks
uh this example of of um uh social
capital and and I I find it a very
acquisitive approach towards Society um
uh you know Capital has its own set of
baggage and perhaps it helps to show the
importance of capital um uh of of so the
social to to equate it to money which of
course we all care about um but you know
social capital is also very strong in
lynch mobs um so it's going to be
important for us uh as we go this
process devel the
ofet Justice yeah Justice and of course
cpra gives us great examples of that um
so
independently showing CA stuff
independently that we have other models
of the kind of Social Capital that we
like to have um so uh as I as we go
through this uh you know what we what
we're hoping to do is to leverage on
some of the research that we've done
around uh Civic media and Technology
I'll give some examples this is the
Melrose mirror uh project called Silver
stringers um uh which was about
increasing conversation between uh
different generational groups and giving
senior citizens a chance to uh develop
uh C Civic based media um Community
journalism that was started in the
mid90s at the media lab um Mitch Resnik
has also been running these computer
clubhouses which are excellent ways of
reformulating the way that children are
introduced to computers not around
productivity or profit but around
education and working in groups uh there
are over 110 of these in 20 countries uh
uh working in community centers um you
know and my group has been working on
radical Technologies like
uh autonomous boats to protest in
Guantanamo um autonomous uavs to keep
track of Minute Men and other
anti-immigrant extremists on the US
Mexico border um projects like uh uh
government information awareness the
flip side to the NSA uh wiretapping
Scandal that we were just noticing in
2002 um where we allowed any individual
to report secret information about
government officials and within seven
hours we had the department of Justice's
internal phone directory and within 12
George Tenet home address uh and the
most recent one which is just launching
now called selectricity which is a
voting technology that allows you to
vote on the most kind of qudian boring
things in your everyday life um uh but
also incorporates uh really excellent
voting algorithms so we're hoping to
kind of extend these and and come up
with new models as Henry said to develop
technologies that kind of really game
the system towards better Civic
space thanks Chris so our next speaker
is Beth novic who's a professor of law
at New York University where she directs
The Institute for information law and
policy and she's the founder and
organizer of the state of play
conferences and an annual event on
Virtual Worlds
research thank you very much thank you
for the introduction and I want to thank
both of you and Mitch as well
congratulations on the Grant and on the
launch of the center it's really an
honor to be here to celebrate with you
and to help launch this important new
initiative by addressing this question
of what do we mean by Civic media and I
think it's wonderful that you've sense
coined a new term and a broader term
which gives us a chance to reflect on
what this research agenda might look
like going forward um so I think we uh
we start of course we come to this and I
think this is sort of riing off of
things that both of you have said with
the fact that the foundation in our
democracy the sort of foundational
concept that's enshrined very much in
the First Amendment and that is is that
the media plays a very Central political
role of helping to Foster the kind of
independent public discussion I love
this quote from Justice brandise the
independent public discussion is a
political Duty and is the fundamental
principle of American government and
this notion that we have to have we
believe in the power of reason as
applied through public discussion and we
have typically viewed the media in its
traditional form as playing a central
role in bringing about reason as applied
through public discussion as the basis
for democracy and the foundation for
Democratic self-government so typically
we've conceptualized the media the
fourth estate as playing a role of
bringing about specifically political
accountability and of course the first
amendment in its Origins was essentially
this protection for a free press that is
supposed to provide a check a critical
check on the work of government and on
institutions of power and in addition to
bring into the public into the public
fry a certain level of expertise a
certain level of information
to help promote political
accountability to create greater
transparency in our institutions and to
fre Forge the basis of a
democracy I'd like to suggest perhaps a
slightly provocative point and it really
is that we need to as you suggested
reinvent what is a romanticized ideal
not only in our media culture but in our
political culture and in our conception
of the role that media is supposed to
play and that is namly that this
deliberative ideal that we've come to
ascribe to the First Amendment and
frankly to democracy more generally is
really to some extent has failed us and
hence our conception of media in its
traditional form is failing us because
the theory that we ascribe to it is that
this notion of the public exchange of
reason the reasoned exchange of public
discourse as the foundation of democracy
it turns out does not actually produce
or lead to political participation and
Robert putnam's examples aside one of
the things that both both of you have
picked up on is that the bowling league
does not somehow translate into some
impact on the world of power it does not
translate into the kind of
accountability into the poit the action
figures in Singapore that we somehow
view as being much more powerful and
therefore potentially much more
interesting than what goes on in the
typical bowling league there's new data
out in some recent work by Diana mut's
very good empirical work that shows that
traditional conceptions of deliberation
of neighbors talking to each other does
not CA correlate not only into voting
every four years but frankly into
political participation or civic
participation more
generally we know that in terms of the
political institutions and the way that
we've set them up that frankly the
deliberative ideal that we're all going
to sit around and talk to our neighbors
and therefore change the way our
political institutions function it
simply doesn't work we feel as
disaffected and as distant from the
workings of Washington or Brussels as
we've ever felt uh now more so than ever
um and that these conceptions of
deliberation when they do work on a
neighborhood level potentially such as a
traditionally political Meetup for
example don't work very well at scale we
haven't been able to bring technology to
Bear to really to realize this vision
for deliberative democracy because
frankly the issues that we're facing are
potentially very complex very
complicated requiring a great deal of
Highly um expert information in in order
to solve the problems that we
potentially face today so I'd like to
suggest perhaps a bit provocatively that
the deliberative ideal that has to a
large extent governed the law and the
policy that have undergirded our vision
of a media system has been not serving
us well and hence it is important to
have this moment of rethinking and
reenvisioning what we mean by Civic
media traditional our traditional
conception of media of course does set
this deliberative ideal rather than the
participatory challenge that both of you
have set out for us it's also come to as
Chris you've made the point very clearly
and this is not only a problem for
technology and Technology markets but
for the me for media to view the
individual as the audience the
individual consumer of media and press
rather than looking at the role that we
can play as networks of producers of
information not simply individual
consumers of
information and our conception also
tends to disregard fact conception of a
professional press I know Ethan is the
one of the people who's been working for
years to debunk the conception of a
professional press um has this takes
this view in fact that you need some
kind of sociological boundary of
professional rather than viewing the
expertise that is distributed and that
is available to us out there in the
diverse knowledge communities that have
come to be available to us today so if
you take any of these examples my news
or news assignment the project that
recently ran through NYU last year uh
places that knowledge are emerging
whether it's the volunteer databas is
created on the Internet Movie Database
or the illustration to the right of it
is the Amazon Mechanical Turk project
Yahoo answers Google answers other
Technologies and projects that have
emerged in order to gather aggregate
knowledge and expertise that is out
there in distributed communities not
simply within the limited confines of
the tradition addal boundaries of media
or press as we have come to know
it so in fact if we think about
Reinventing we have to Tok phille of
course always had everything right when
the right of every citizen to cooperate
in the government of societies
acknowledged every citizen every citizen
must be presumed to possess the power of
discriminating between different
opinions of his contemporaries and
appreciating the different facts from
which inferences may be drawn so in fact
what we're seeing as a result of the
technology that's that is becoming
available to us and the examples that
both of you have shown already is that
it is the right of every citizen and of
all of us working together not
alone exclusive of the traditional
boundaries of media as we have come to
know it so as Henry wrote this morning
on his blog Civic media refers to any
medium which Fosters or enhances Civic
engagement as we've been discussing this
kind of participation I would argue
rather than simply the
Liberation that has underscored and
undergirded the way we have organized
and thought about and theorized about
our conception of the press to dat a
conception which is much more about
action than it is simply about talk so
what I want to do is to give a few
examples apparently more loudly I need
to give my examples it's actually my
typing that's the problem rather oh it's
it's what I get for trying to blog on
stage so it's a sound of productivity in
the background it sounds very it's like
The Newsroom going in the background the
teletype going um okay so we'll do this
um so what I want to do is to take the
few minutes that are remaining to me to
speak a little bit about what this call
to action might look like and if we take
up this new idea of the Civic
media rather than simply a deliberative
media rather not simply talking about
talk but talking about action as the
basis for the First Amendment as the the
basis for strengthening democracy not as
voting every four years but as a
lifestyle as something that we do every
day how do we begin to think about not
simply the Civic in the sense of
relationships on a social basis among
and between us in our local communities
but how do we think about building the
bridges between the Technologies of
Civic media what people refer to by the
shorthand sometimes of Web 2.0 I should
put that in quotes since I'm not too
fond of it but it fits nicely on a slide
um but building the bridge between Web
2.0 the content that we're developing
together in networks in distributed
networks and the institutions of power
how do we think about building those
bridges between the worlds of shall we
say what we're doing every day now to
create that content and the traditional
worlds of Law and
politics what are the new models by
which we can begin to work with and
develop the these new open sources of
information so yesterday I was in
Washington at a meeting about the energy
environment and
intelligence so in other words the
question was environmental crises are
increasingly becoming crises of
intelligence and security and the
Mandate for the workshop was to figure
out how we could bring distributed
intelligence to Bear how we could take
Flickr and YouTube and you know all and
World of Warcraft and figure out how to
do things like in investigate or
identify environmental hot zones before
they become political crisis because of
course the intelligence and the
information that we're Gathering about
the environment about
energy translate into very important
questions about how we spend resources
how we make policy and potentially the
even more important question of where we
send troops where we send people to live
and to die to protect a against
potentially these natural disasters so
it was it was an interesting meeting
simply because there was a whole group
of very highlevel people talking in a
language that I understood nothing of
having to do with Environmental Policy
but focusing on this issue of how do we
take these new Civic media and make
these institutions of power better and
I'll tell you that the sponsor for the
mean I know I'm being recorded here but
I'm probably already being watched
anyway since the real sponsor for the
meeting was the CIA looking at since the
question was this is viewed as an issue
of security and how do we translate
again how do we draw these Bridges and
what are the models by which we do this
what are the affordances of the
technology that could enable us to
create the new models for accountability
the new models for expertise and again
not simply a deliberative vision of
everybody talking all of the time but
tapping the wisdom that is out there not
just the wisdom of the crowd but the
wisdom that resides in specific
communities and bringing it to Bear to
make public life better and more
effective and I think as we begin to
think about this and I would view this
as you know not surely the project for
the next 10 minutes in a PowerPoint but
potentially the project um and the
questions that those of us who study and
research in this area need to work on is
to figure out both what works and also
what doesn't work for peer production
and open models of collaboration are not
the answer to everything they're not the
magic sort of um as a friend of mine
refers to the magic pixie dust
um that solves all of our political
woses that will make democracy
automatically better we have a lot of
hard work to do between now and January
20th 2009 a date I'm looking forward to
um in order to make democracy better but
there are things that we can do and they
depend very specifically the answers the
models depend very specifically on the
questions so let me just illustrate with
a couple of examples a couple of more
visual examples um to suggest the ways
in which the new kinds of Civic media
might be brought to bear uh to affect
the institutions of political power and
as such to strengthen democracy well it
turns out it's pretty good what we're
pretty good at is identifying gaps in
information and finding information so
if the question is how do I figure out
what is the next environmental Hot Zone
or in this case the way I've been
spending my time for the last two years
how do I find out what is the scientific
information that is relevant to the
examination of a patent
application it turns out the web is a
pretty good way to do that and that we
can organize the model by which we can
get at very very structured pieces of
information so the peer to patent
project has spent the last we launched
on June 15th but we've been working on
this for a little while now trying to
figure out the very very specific
process and structured process by which
to gather the information that we need
to answer this question of what is the
information out there that will help to
determine whether an invention deserves
the grant of a 20year monopoly right to
exclude all others from practicing an
invention we know increasingly that
patents play a very significant role in
our economy that the rate of patenting
is doubled over the last 10 years that
the rate of patent litigation has
similarly gone up and patent litigation
starts at a minimum of a million dollars
a case so we're talking about vast
expenditures going into litigation
instead of R&D patents being granted at
enormous rates because the patent office
is so backlogged and so lacking in the
information that it needs to figure out
whether something deserves the grant of
a patent or not and in turn is granting
too many bad patents so this is not a
lecture about patent law what I want to
say is that this is an example this is a
paradigm and the reason we took on this
project was as a way to experiment
empirically with the idea of how do we
use an open Community distributed
Community to find specific information
so I'll put up uh a just some data about
what the project is which is essentially
a year-long pilot to develop the model
for doing open expertise in government a
model which could equally be well
applied in transportation in environment
to to other intelligence questions
having nothing to do with the patent
office but for the fact that the patent
office of course particularly baguer by
the lack of information and the need for
good scientific information one of the
other things that it turns out we can do
extremely well is we can bring diverse
expertise to a problem so if what we
need to do and this is partly hearkens
back to the deliberative ideal is to get
at really good information to answer a
question well it turns out that opening
up the way that we get at information is
a very useful way to do that this is a a
survey that we did after one month into
the project and what it shows is there a
very diverse level of participation in
terms of the variety of so-called
experts not Professionals in that these
are not patent lawyers these are not
even all scientists they're not even
patent professionals what they are
people coming from a diverse array of a
diverse range of professions but who all
have expertise and enthusiasm to bring
to a problem and diverse perspectives to
bring on getting
information now switching to other
people's projects um what it turns out
we can also do fairly well is to make
sense of data so where there's a large
quantity of data and there are lots of
examples this I just picked uh the
census project coming down the down the
street from IBM research um some of you
may have seen this what they've been
very good is providing the tools to help
other people make sense particularly
visual sense of census
data um and it turns out that the visual
Technologies and the visual affordances
of the computer screen are enormously
useful for helping us to connect the
worlds of information expertise and
power I me mention another example uh up
there cpc.org I often show um slides
from them so I don't want to do it today
but I want to point it out to you
because it's a wonderful example of
getting communities involved senior
citizens and high school students
together in making sense of local land
use data in order to police the
conditions of use in their own
communities what Civic media distinctly
from traditional media also does I think
is helps contribute enthusiasm to a
problem and perhaps more important than
anything it's not so much information or
expertise but enthusiasm a sense of fun
a sense of Engagement a sense of
willingness to work on a problem um and
here are some examples of course from
Second Life the tax protests uh up in
the upper leftand corner you'll see an
example from our Island democracy Island
where a number of protests have taken
place and other kinds of Civic activism
that have been spontaneously organized
by people on the island it's one of the
best project I've ever run I have to say
because I've never never done anything
on this project all we did was open up
the island call it democracy Island and
invited as a result other people to do
their work to do their projects and to
bring their enthusiasm to a platform
that we offered I like to refer to
myself as a democracy slum Lord um
because we provided essentially the real
estate for other people to experiment
with creating things like you can't
quite see um maybe I have this somewhere
in here the uh floating deliberation
room the three-dimensional Wiki for
doing Urban Land Use I think I have a
picture of that in a
moment uncovering
assumptions smart vote coming out of
Switzerland being used now for their
upcoming election some of you may have
seen this lets you have fun um if you
speak French German or Italian or even
if you don't um you can go in and answer
a series of political questions and then
see a set of visualizations that show
you the extent to which your political
candidates actually match a set of
assumptions about policy and politics um
so what we can do very well using the
tools that we might design and build and
that are beginning to be built is in
cover assumptions about often very
opaque and very complex political
data scenario planning the kind of
activity that I was called to to do in
Washington can be very well done using
distributed media to bring together
people who share the enthusiasm and can
use the visual Technologies available to
themselves to engage in developing ideas
about scenario planning policy planning
all kinds of difficult and complex
political questions this enables us to
draw do things like visualize linkages
and connections by making the data
readily available this is again from
this is the Smart spider tool that comes
off of um SM the smart vote site and it
turns out the folks from the burkman
center will be amused to know that by
randomly answering a set of questions I
am perfectly politically matched in
Switzerland to the wife of the one of
the Berk Center fellows who is running
for political office that is a total
coincidence but I'm very pleased um
should I vote in Switzerland I would
vote for her um in fact I answered the
questions in Italian I don't even speak
Italian so you know it's my horoscope is
such that I am destined uh uh I knew I
liked her anyway um very good also for
doing things like what we might think of
as breaking the government Log Jam and
this is my transition of course to Ethan
um who will I'm sure talk about the
global voices project
um transparency breaking up corruption
making people aware of political
problems um bringing attention to an
issue and then of course doing things
about it not just talking about it being
able to take action by using the visual
medium that's available to them and
using the tools that are available to
them to actually um make things happen
so just a few thoughts and
Reflections on how we might revisit the
deliberative ideal this is my Jean jacqu
rouso picture in case you're wondering
it is not Thomas Jefferson although it
could have been um but what this what
the potential is is for civic media to
help us Foster the first amendment in
new ways to really think about and and I
think you've already expressed this
point well strengthen our democracy by
doing not just by talking by making
government more accountable not simply
through a traditional conception of the
press but through the new conception of
media that we're inventing today through
the technologies that we're developing
the visual Technologies the group-based
Technologies the Network Technologies
that allow us to come together not to
bowl alone but as I put it to click
together to enable us to bring
information to Bear to make better
decisions in government to make better
decisions in institutions and ultimately
to connect Civic media to power thank
you thank you very
much
[Applause]
so our final speaker today is Ethan
Zuckerman he's a fellow at the burkman
center for internet and Society at the
Harvard Law School and he's the
co-founder of the website's Global
voices which he created with Rebecca
McKinnon and geek
core well thanks and uh thanks for
having me here I'm looking forward to
spending more time here I'm I'm from uh
the Exotic far off part of town over
that other little University on the
other out out of town but um the same uh
Grant that's supporting uh the new Civic
Media Center is also supporting some of
the work that we're doing over at Global
voices so I I think I'm going to be
invited over here at least once a year
uh for our Roundup uh and I appreciate
the fact that even before that round up
I got invited over I I did realize that
i' made a terrible fuxon sitting here
which is that I didn't have a single
Robert putam or bowling reference in my
slide deck so as I sort of sat here
listening to the three previous speakers
I I tried to figure out what I could do
uh to address the issue of bowling also
in the context of the Civic media site
that I run the problem that we have is
that when you go onto a site like Global
voices which looks only at the
developing world and you search for
bowling uh you end up with endless
stories about Cricket um and this sense
in which um you bring a technology into
a different context and you get a
different result is is really sort of a
theme in many ways of the work that I've
been doing for the last couple of years
because a lot of the technology that
we're looking at is Tech technology that
to one extent or another has premiered
uh in the United States or in Western
Europe but is often being used in very
very different ways and often very
innovative ways uh in the developing
world so when we think about citizen
media and we think about this in a US
context we often sort of start our
history uh with Howard Dean and the dean
scream or if we have a bit more history
uh with Dave Wier and uh screaming about
various technology issues um but it's
basically uh white guys screaming um and
and you know this generally found um we
found ourselves uh sort of becoming
politically important when it looked
like this phenomenon of white guys
screaming online uh might actually have
some political relevance or at least
some relevance in in raising money this
sort of seminal moment uh within
blogging and the developing World um
happening actually a little bit before
not really in parallel but happening as
early as 2001 um is solom Po's blog uh
which many of you have probably heard of
this was a Blog of an iroi arch
uh who was writing about his experiences
living in Baghdad um as we were all
getting ready for the US invasion and
does anyone have any idea why this is so
dark yeah we'll get over it um anyway
part of what was so interesting with
solemn pox was that not only uh did you
get sense for what was going on sort of
politically you know where were the
roadblocks how safe was it was there
electricity or not you started also
finding out very very personal details
of this young man's life where he talks
about his sexual cities and his fondness
for beer and essentially challenging a
lot of the images that many of us had of
what an ordinary Iraqi might look like
we began referring to this phenomenon as
the phenomenon of bridge blogging
someone using uh web2.0 readwrite media
whatever the heck we want to call this
to challenge your sort of assumptions
about a part of the world uh and one of
the better examples of this uh is a Blog
called mud's Den uh mmud is uh an
entrepreneur in Bak
um he's a fascinating guy and over the
course of sort of reading his blog for a
few years I found myself uh challenging
a lot of perceptions that I have of the
Gulf region one of the most moving posts
was him talking about uh bringing his
12-year-old daughter to the Formula 1
racetrack in Bahrain and encouraging her
to become a race car driver if that's
what she wanted to do or maybe just
encouraging her to be a race car driver
I'm not entirely sure um but on his
personal statement on this blog when he
started it he has this wonderful
paragraph
now I try to dispel the image that
Muslims and Arabs suffer from Mostly by
our own doing I have to say in the rest
of the world I am no missionary and
don't want to be I run several internet
websites that are geared to do just that
create a better understanding that we're
all that we're not all nuts hellbent on
world destruction I hope I will be
judged that I made a small difference
and while a lot of the people who are
involved with this phenomenon of bridge
bloging aren't quite as explicit about
their intentions there's quite a bit of
overlap between it uh we did a survey of
people in our community about why
they're engaged in this process of
writing online and and donating a huge
amount of time to sort of document
what's going on in citizen media in the
developing world and the biggest reason
was patriotism nationalism people who
desperately wanted to make sure that
their nation and their culture was
represented online in the digital media
and that's really the impulse with which
we started this project was attempting
to take a look at a world in which there
were 70 million people writing online
and blogs it at least as many writing
online in forums um a small set of
people uh producing online in podcasts
and video casts and some small subset
we're not writing just for a personal
audience not just for family and friends
but literally to build some bridges
internationally now what's interesting
is as we got into it we started figuring
out that this phenomenon this bridge
blogging phenomenon was probably a
minority and that actually there were
some really other interesting phenomena
going on and and my guide to this
phenomena to a large extent uh is the
guy on the left uh that's Al abdal fata
uh this is shortly after his release
from prison we'll get to how he ended up
in prison in just a moment but Al is
sort of a fascinating figure in the
Egyptian
blogosphere um he runs a blogging
platform that a huge number of Egyptians
use uh many of them are activists
involved with a CFA movement kafaya just
simply means enough we've had enough of
Mubarak it's a very broad political
movement it brings to together student
movements communist movements islamist
movements basically if you're against
Mubarak you can be part of kafaya um
he's also a geek uh and he's a Drupal
developer and he's an open source
developer and so he's this really
interesting Nexus of this sort of
activist blogging community and one of
the things that he and his friends found
themselves doing was essentially
creating an alternative media to the
media that they were encountering in
Egypt because generally speaking no
matter how big a protest he his cfia
friends managed to get together they
didn't get any attention in mainstream
Egyptian newspapers and so at a certain
point in the process they realized that
every time that they set out to do a
protest they actually had to do two
things they had to plan the protest and
then they had to plan their own media
coverage of the protest and so they
ended up essentially building mobile
newsrooms based around mobile phone
cameras SMS messages back to someone who
was at home typing on a laptop and you
found these guys providing extremely
detailed cover coverage of their rallies
and in some cases other people's rallies
one of the most moving examples of this
was uh a movement by sudanes refugees
who were living in Cairo protesting at
their treatment by
unhcr and the way that most of us found
out about this particular protest was
the fact that kafaya covered it so they
went and started covering other people's
protests as well because again they felt
like there were movements taking place
in Egypt that literally no one was
reporting on now what's interesting
about this is that at one of these
movements uh Al found himself arrested
along with 800 other activists was a
peaceful protest for an independent
Egyptian Judiciary and Al found himself
in prison and he started doing something
very odd from prison he started blogging
uh and by the way there's a key to
blogging in prison I highly recommend
this for anyone who's planning on doing
this you need to make sure that your
spouse is a blogger um because that's
how you do it you write or Draw on paper
you pass it off to your spouse who scans
it in who posts it online uh my wife is
a blogger I highly recommend that you
find yourself a nice blogger to pair up
with if you're planning on getting into
trouble but blogging from prison gave a
very unusual perspective to what was
going on in this otherwise uneventful
protest ale ended up spending something
like three months in prison much much
longer than anyone had expected and it
was in part because the fact that he was
blogging online and that people started
blogging in support of him Drew
International attention to this so what
would have been a tiny little incident
in Egypt turned into this sort of global
incident around the power of blogging
and the phenomenon of blogging from
prison and he ended up being literally
the last guy to be released from prison
but he also Drew more attention to the
situation than almost anyone else had
what this has meant though is that we
now see Al and some of these other
activists as sort of lead users of uh
web Technologies and sort of adapting
them to their own purposes so this is
truth my least favorite Web 2.0
technology this is Twitter this allows
you to say in a very small number of
characters what meaningless thing you're
doing at this time uh if I were Robert
scoble I would be here with my mobile
phone saying I am on stage giving a
presentation and everyone would know
that I'm on stage giving a presentation
and well this is stunningly boring to
read in most people's lives it's
actually pretty interesting when your
friends are human rights activists
because what they're able to say is I'm
going into prison right now being
questioned if not out in 5 hours please
you know start the fre site again and
this has actually been tremendously
successful uh a lot of people subscribe
to this you can get it via your SMS and
so what happens in some cases is that Al
has said things like they're arresting
this guy monem they're taking him from
this Square to this police station and
people reading the twitters were able to
actually get on the street and stop the
police car physically from sort of
manifesting to uh to to to block its
progress now Al is sort of an easy
example to to point to because he's
generally writing in English but the
real power behind this in Egypt uh is
with the Muslim Brotherhood and you say
Muslim Brotherhood in this country and
people sort of freak out but Muslim
Brotherhood is pretty much the best
organized opposition party in Egypt at
this point and what's very very
interesting is that as there's been a
Crackdown on Muslim Brotherhood it's
focused disproportionately on
brotherhood members who are blogging
online um and the most visible of those
is a guy named Abdel monam um and he has
basically been training Brotherhood
figures on how to use blogs to organize
locally and also how to promote
themselves and as a result is now um
recently was released but is now spent
two terms in prison two short times
under detention very much because he's
become a figure of interest because this
technology has made it possible to take
something which is a movement which is
really quite quiet if you're not
watching Egypt closely and try to bring
it to Global profile so one of my
observations on citizen media and
possibly Civic media although I've
certainly thought about citizen
journalism more than about Civic media
is that it tends to show up in your
moderately repressive Nations um and
we're going to call Egypt for these
terms a moderately repressive Nation by
which I mean you are not in fact going
to disappear by standing up and staging
a public protest it is not a North Korea
it's not a Turkmenistan I should take
Burma off this list because Burma
actually looks like it's being
significantly more flexible than it used
to be
citizen media doesn't appear to Blossom
at the same rate in low repression
Nations and one of the reasons for this
is that there's other paths into media
uh in Ghana where I've done a lot of my
work over the last couple of years we
keep waiting for blogging to take off
and one of the reasons that blogging
doesn't seem to take off is that it's
really easy to call into a talk radio
station and talk radio is actually a
much better space for civic discourse in
Ghana right now than it is to do it
online online is really useful if you
want to talk to the expat population but
frankly the expats are listening to the
radio on the web anyway and they're
calling in as well and in Ghana on most
morning shows there's one of the
ministers who is on Joy FM and if you
have a problem with your Road in your
District you speak to the minister on
the air when you have a government that
that's that high functioning there isn't
as much space for this but in places
where it's very very difficult to get
access to that media space you see
people moving in and using these tools
now you also see governments moving back
and saying let's find a way not to use
these tools um over at burkeman we're
involved with a project called open net
initiative and open net initiative is
documenting what countries are filtering
the internet and for what reasons and
one of the things that's become very
very clear is that countries that have a
great deal of control over their press
are starting to wake up to the notion
that they might also need to control the
online space and we see in at least two
dozen Nations significant control over
what sites you can access access and
this affects in some cases uh socially
undesirable sites it's tough to look at
Playboy from within Saudi Arabia that
tends to creep into politically
undesirable sites it's very very tough
to read opposition websites in Ethiopia
the trend that really bothers me is that
it's also crossing over into the tools
of free speech and it's getting harder
and harder to access a tool like
blogger.com in a country like Pakistan
and I see this is a very very worrisome
development even more worrisome is the
fact that in many cases the corporations
are in on the deal um Microsoft spaces
is the most popular non-chinese produced
blogging tool in China and one of the
reasons that Microsoft spaces is able to
operate so freely in China is that they
built a service very much designed to
make Chinese sensors happy so this is a
screenshot from my colleague Rebecca
McKinnon who is conveniently fluent in
Chinese who tried to create a blog on
MSN spaces titled I love freedom of
speech human rights and democracy and
the message that she got back reads you
must enter a title for your space the
title must not contain prohibited
languages such as profanity please type
a different title so once you bake
censorship into the tools you can govern
certain forms of behavior but one of the
reasons we're really optimistic about
these tools is something that I call uh
the cute cat theory of web activism
which is to say that we all know that
the reason for web2.0 is to share
pictures of cute cats uh with or without
captions and the nice thing about this
is that any tool that allows you to
share cute cats also has a political use
um so you could show a cute video of
your cat but you can also show videos of
Union protests and the truth is there's
a social cost for censoring these sites
because people want to look at cute cat
photos and so if you cut down access to
flicker.com people get really upset but
if people have access to flickr.com in
many cases they also have access to the
pictures of the protests and so it's a
balancing act for governments that want
to close down these tools so anyway I
want of the hypotheses that I'm
exploring right now is the idea that the
level of online censorship is basically
a function of how censorious the
government is offline and how far it's
proceeded along closing the digital
divide which is to say that if no one in
your country has access to the internet
there's really no reason to censor it
someone should tell Ethiopia this by the
way which has gone ahead and gone ahead
and censored it very aggressively
despite the fact that so few people have
access but this is one of the critical
things that we have to consider in all
of this this is incidentally if you work
in ICT for development this slide is
mandatory to put in a presentation you
you have to throw in the the the NASA
Earth at night slide because it's a very
profound reminder that the space that
we're working in is a space right now
that connects at best about a billion
people and that a lot of the people that
I'm working with are connected
indirectly at best if anyone is
influenced by the Internet it's because
a wealthy friend in a major city is able
to get to the internet and might be able
to pass some of the news along and so
Civic media in these contexts can't just
be internet media we have to think about
other methods this is an amazing project
in the Democratic Republic of Congo it's
called interactive radio for justice and
the way that it works is it tries to
make it possible for people in congales
villages to ask questions of authority
and these questions get pretty basic at
some point one popular question is hey
there's 10 soldiers sleeping in my house
and they're eating all my cassava they
tell me that I'm legally required to
give them as much Ava as I can and house
them in my house are they right now this
is a slightly dangerous question to ask
and so you actually want to ask it
anonymously specifically you want to ask
it via an SMS message because there's a
good chance that if you're in Congo you
have access to an SMS phone but then you
want to put the question in front of the
right people and in this case it's the
Minister of Justice and uh the minister
of the military of DRC and the head of
monok which is the UN monitoring agency
and then you want to spread out the
message in an appropriate way which in
this case is AM radio because AM radio
really is the universal technology
nowadays so citizen media Civic media
can't just be digital media it's got to
be creative ways of creating two-way
media great example in Zimbabwe right
now most zimbabweans at this point are
desperately trying to figure out how to
feed themselves in a country where
literally people have stopped making
bread because the government won't let
them sell it at a profit anymore and
where the amount of money that would buy
you that loaf of bread red would buy you
a four-bedroom house 6 months ago but
one of the few things that continues to
work is the mobile phone system and so
my friends over at kubatana are polling
people Via mobile phone to get their
reactions to topics are you going to
participate in the next strike or not is
it worth doing or not the web becomes
the medium to press that message out to
the general public but SMS is the right
medium to get that message in and the
reason for that is that we're now at a
point where we've got over a 100 million
handsets in an African context 300
million in China 2.2 billion worldwide
for the vast majority of people in the
world this is not the content generation
device that they care about it's the
mobile phone even in Tanzania which is
very very poor you've now got 70 97% of
people saying not that they own a phone
but if they needed to access one they
could and that's a remarkable statistic
that's a level of connectivity that's
really unprecedented in human history
and this has really come about in The
Last 5 Years or so
one of the other amazing things about
mobile phones is that they let you
become part of a surveillance Network
because in most cases they've got a
camera and because you can take that
image from that camera and spread it to
the rest of the world you can do what
Steve man who used to wander around here
wearing computers on his head used to
talk about which is finding ways to
monitor systems of power one of the ways
that we're seeing this in the developing
world is very literally elections
monitoring and this is from a Nigerian
project that didn't work very well but
I'll tell you about a Ganan project that
worked very very well um in 2000 you may
have remembered we had an election here
in the United States it didn't go so
well um Ghana had one as well and it
went really really well uh and one of
the reasons that it went so well was
actually the the first time that someone
had taken power in a coup was voted out
in a peaceful fashion one of the reasons
it works so well is that people
monitored polling sites they would go to
polling sites with mobile phones and if
they saw voter intimidation they
wouldn't call the police because it's
possible the police might fail to file
the report they would call radio
stations and they would read their
reports out on the air so suddenly
something that one person is witnessing
is then heard by thousands or tens of
thousands of people and there was
remarkably little election violence in
2000 in part because everybody was
watching so one of the themes of my work
and particularly my work around this
question of Citizen media in the
developing world is a question of what
we're watching and my assertion is going
to be that one of the biggest problems
and one of the ones that we rarely look
at is not these digital divide problems
is not the censorship problems but is an
attention
problem this is a map of media attention
this is a very quick and dirty analysis
of Google news this basically involves
going to Google news on a given day and
saying how many stories do you have
about France and how many do you have
about Greenland and putting them up on a
map and you do this with different media
sources and you get remarkably
consistent looking Maps the red parts of
these maps are high attention countries
almost always North America almost
always Western Europe the huge powers of
the world India and China and always the
Middle East I have literally never seen
Israel anything other than bright red on
this map the blues are the countries
that we're not paying much attention to
always subsaharan Africa always uh
Central America always Central Asia
consistent over the course of four years
I have bad news for you I've started
doing this with blogs as well and the
map doesn't get any different it really
doesn't change substantially this is
looking at Tech's most authoritative
blog same technique who wrote about
China today who wrote about France today
who wrote about South Africa today and
the answer is as much as we would love
to believe that this participatory media
we're building suddenly means that we're
going to start paying attention to
Madagascar we don't and we're not in
many cases we're simply reinforcing
what's already out there in existing
media so this is one of the central
challenges that I find myself wrestling
with which is how do we convince people
to pay some attention to madag gasar and
what are the obstacles that we have to
overcome in that process one of the ones
is language they speak malagi who knew I
thought they spoke French I only found
out about this because there's actually
a huge blogger movement uh in Madagascar
at the moment a very highly political
blogosphere that we've started
translating from we've also started
translating into malag
um this is one of the really interesting
things about this project is that we're
trying very much to be volunteer driven
we've done coverage of countries where
people have stood up and said there's
blogging going on in my country I want
to tell you about it and we translate
from and into languages where people
have stood up and said hey I'll happily
translate your site on a daily basis
into
malagasy it turns out that translation
is only a tiny part of the problem
there's a much bigger part of the
problem if you're looking at Chinese
blogs this probably has become a fairly
familiar image to you uh and I'm
guessing that it probably isn't a
familiar image to most of you in there
but it is obviously a river crab wearing
three watches so you know the question
then becomes why is it a river crab
wearing three watches and and the reason
for this is uh the word hii uh which
means to harmonize um has basically been
the term that the Chinese government is
using for censoring online speech uh and
bloggers are responding to this say
saying oh man my blog just got
harmonized and in fact harmonized has
become so popular in talking about
censorship that the word harmonize now
will frequently get your blog blocked
now fortunately the word for River crab
HEI um sounds and I can't pronounce
either of these words so um sounds
fairly similar and so people now on
Chinese blogs talk about their blogs
being River crapped um now the same
thing sort of happened with a political
philosophy called the three represents
that became very controversial got
blocked in many cases
someone found a way to slightly rewrite
the phrase where's three watches and you
now see Chinese bloggers putting up this
image of a river crab with three watches
on it or making their own images of it
as a way of essentially making visual
puns about
censorship this is the challenge you
know most of us within this audience can
look at a map like this and say geeez I
would really like to know more about
what's going on in the world I have a
genuine interest in it the challenge in
doing this is that by putting these
tools of authorship into people's hands
you don't know what you're going to get
out of it and you may not be the
audience for it and to have the
capability of engaging with it it
requires a great deal of context and a
great deal of translation to become part
of it so I've been giving this talk a
lot lately and have been basically
saying that this is a talk against cyber
optimism this is a talk against this
notion that we're suddenly going to have
a network and we're all going to be
connected and we're all going to hold
hands and sing Kumbaya
and the long version of this talk by the
way talks about how badly people in the
US and Nigeria treat one another uh
between spams and between scam baiting
and sort of back and forth and that's
that's the hourlong version if you ever
want it sometimes but I the point that I
should make particularly in this context
is that I'm engaged in this work because
I'm profoundly a cyber Optimist I think
this is possible by virtue of the fact
that I am working with people in
Madagascar right now to figure out
what's going on politically in
Madagascar I am much closer much more
interested much more connected to that
Nation than I have any reason or right
to be and that's the potential of this
medium it's just a whole lot harder uh
than we thought it was when we started
wiring everybody together in the 1970s
so I'll stop there thank
you all right we have time for we have
about a little over 35 minutes for
questions uh if people would line up the
mics we would appreciate it this is not
just for amplification but also because
we're we podcast and webcast these
events and we'd like to ask and for that
reason if you'd identify yourself when
you asked your question uh looks like a
steady a fair number of people so but
you're first in line sir so if you wanna
hi there be on yes hi my name is John
John Garfunkle and uh thank you all very
much thank you especially Ethan because
the slide you had up for fre that's my
name is on that slide and um that's one
of the places I'm proud to have my name
on the Internet so I hope that stays up
a while um but I I was a bit involved
with that and if Mary Joyce is here um
she had helped me get involved last year
on that uh but I thank you all for the
presentations I have two questions to
think about I think you guys have like a
year or five to think them over um one
just on on Beth's comments I was in my
own research on Civic media I've noticed
there 's one activity we do which is the
social aspect which gets a lot of
interest social media we all hear but
there's also the doing and the
productivity I've actually been calling
that constructive media thanks to
Seymour paper's work inspired by it so
that's one thing to keep in mind as you
think about Technologies or I'm asking
about how
your uh program will try and balance
those both the the social and then the
productive or constructive as I say it
um and just one other question to put
out there you don't have to you can just
think about it was um following Civic
media citizens media some of the things
that don't get looked at as well are
problems about ordinary people uh
especially with
reputation and and Reporting Network
abuse which happens with Anonymous
forums with Google searches Etc so it's
I'm just curious if that's in your stew
your mix of things to consider going
forward thank
you it was directed to you so I'm
although I was but I'm not sure well it
sounds both both extremely good um
worthwhile for reflection let me just
say to the first point especially that
um by way a bit of plug in some sense is
I I share your view about the need for
constructive media which is why that
despite the fact that I not only play a
lawyer on TV but I am a lawyer um and
I'm interested and as a lawyer
interested in the in the goal of problem
solving and social Justice is that I
view that the way that we bring that
about is by a combination of Technology
law and policy all brought together and
working in tandem so part of you know
the purpose in showing some of these
tools and I didn't have as much time as
I would have liked today we I could have
talked just about sort of the design
elements the affordances of these tools
that create certain you know Empower
certain types of people and Ethan talked
for example about AM radio which is a
wonderful example of empowering certain
groups and how we disenfranchise other
people in the way we design the but I
think that the project very much has to
be about designing and Chris made this
point too very much about designing for
communities rather than simply designing
for individuals designing for these
purposes constructing for these purposes
and because if we view media in a social
context we're talking about not only
designing software or media radio
television whatever the tool may be but
we're talking about designing the
institutional political legal contexts
that support these things so you know
search is one very good example of this
in which um you know I and and there are
people you so this is so yes the just to
say it's a very good comment and
important reflection and I think to my
mind the the important need for
interdisciplinary research and work in
this area to have all of us
collaborating towards bringing about you
know complex solutions to increasingly
complex problems and that means it's not
technology for technology sake um which
is why all of us are we're no longer
cyber optimists what was the were cyber
realists what were we 10 years ago I
think we're techno realists also born up
here in Cambridge techno realism um and
part of being a techno realism realist
is seeing the technology and social
context so in terms of the the MIT
Center I think both sides of what you
proposed are very much part of what
we're thinking Civic media is that the
definition I began with was intended to
be broad so that we could support
through the collaboration between
comparative media studies and the media
lab you know many different kinds of
projects from many different groups of
the lab from many different aspects of
what we've been doing in comparative
media studies and we definitely think of
journalistic projects social networking
projects tools that enable people to
construct their own media you know those
are all part of the spectrum of what we
work with so the goal is to during a
number of projects each year that are
played out in a number of different
kinds of communities across the country
and internationally that that that will
be testing grounds for new tools and new
social processes um
next
yes hi uh my name is shavan and I'm
development director for the tour
project which I've worked with Ethan and
few people around here um and I got
involved in it because I'm a blogger and
I have a Blog at iconoclasm do
gather.com which does media criticism
about stories behind news
stories microphone doesn't love me
whoa um so but I work with the tour
project and I'm actually feeling a
little bit of blogosphere fatigue right
now because for three weeks in a row we
have had news stories that got slash
dotted and because they got slash dotted
misinformation got propagated through
the internet faster than my you know 80
words per minut
could keep up with comment roles to try
to tell people what was actually going
on so we got one week associated with
the storm worm we got associated with uh
some guy in Sweden who sniffed Embassy
passwords uh and this week it broke that
one of our uh one of our our server
operators decided to not be a volunteer
for us and be a server operator because
the German police knocked on his door at
midnight and roughed him and his family
up and arrested him and then said oh
terribly sorry it was all a big
mistake and what I want to talk to you
about is I am an optimist about this but
I hear all these people talking
about
deliberation versus the wisdom of crowds
and I wonder about how as the speed of
information increases we can keep Civic
uh media
civil and non
hysterical and actually something
approaching the
fact you want to start with well sure I
I I feel your pain because um one of the
things that I've done is actually
written a number of uh guides to
blogging anonymously and posting
anonymously most of which uh rely on
tour and as these shock waves sort of
propagate out I'm now getting the emails
from the different corners of the globe
and the Philippines checked in this
morning I'll expect Zimbabwe tomorrow to
sort of you know find out whether they
think I've sold them entirely down the
river um I'm hoping that someone who
works on information Theory can actually
conclusively prove that disinformation
actually spreads faster than correct
information I actually think it's uh it
has something to do with the signal
ratio but um I think
unfortunately this is reality and and I
think the fatigue that some of us feel
when the the blogosphere bites us back
is you know precisely the same fatigue
that people who miss the nice civil
world of mainstream journalism where
someone writes an article and you could
call the editor and storm off and have a
correction the next day um find
themselves when they suddenly find
themselves in Wikipedia with completely
inaccurate biographical details and so
on and so forth and unfortunately the
only advice that I ever have for my
friends who end up dealing with this
whether they're in the NGO sector or
whether they're in other sectors this
deal with it I mean this is
unfortunately the reality of this world
it's an extremely quickly shifting
landscape the rules of it are I think
still evolving and this notion that
we're all so rapidly connected and so
perpetually connected and now I've got a
great web browser on my phone and I'm
going to be connected even when I didn't
think I was going to be connected
radically changes how everyone has to do
messaging the people who work well
within the space I think are the people
who simply realize that that's how the
messages propagate now and you know
specifically on the tour case Andrew Lee
I a couple of other people are out there
essentially saying no no no don't worry
and we're hoping that that somehow
propagates at the same Pace but I don't
think there's anything else that works
other than figuring out how those tools
work figuring out how those Dynamics
work and trying to ride the same way I
don't see any other way out of it at
this point yeah it's very easy to
romanticize the the LA the kind of
misinformation contained in professional
media right any of us who are an
academic and offer any sort of
progressive critique of our society and
IM have experienced what happens when
you talk to the Press on certain issues
and see them reduced to sound bites and
the stored uh could say that
misinformation circulates even faster
when you got the power of broadcasting
behind it or the power of a major
newspaper behind it I my friend Alex
juhas has been doing work on YouTube and
teaching a class this term and has
apparently been run through the ringer
the last couple of weeks for teaching
lonely girl 15 instead of Shakespeare
you know without with no attempt no
ability for most of the coverage to be
able to express what she actually is
teaching what the goals of the course
are why you would teach a course on
YouTube at the present time and so forth
so I think whenever we set up the
dangers of participatory culture we at
least need to parallel it with an
understanding of the dangers of the old
system which also what I about
exactly I just say keep the faith and
keep doing the good work
so um hi my name is Tom cookie uh and I
work for British Telecom um and I'm a a
programmer so most of what You' said
kind of just pushed over my head back
there um but I'm going to ask a question
anyway um well not really ask a question
have you ever heard of um e
petitions I have
sure right so how do you think that fits
into the um this uh social media that
you're talking about and do you think
it's actually do you think governments
are actually going to listen to these
petitions that are being put
forward nope I well I mean I'll tell you
about the petition that I ran um about a
year and a half ago my North Asia editor
a young man named wuh how um got
arrested by the Chinese government uh
and detained in Beijing uh was never
actually charged with a crime but ended
up spending uh four and a half months in
custody uh getting questioned every day
and as we started talking about wo
House's case people were really
insistent that they wanted to do
something um and we urged people to call
their legislators in the US and you know
asked to have his name added basically
to the list of people that we beg the
Chinese to release every time we sit
down with the Chinese but most people
don't want to do that most people wanted
something simpler uh and something that
they were very excited about doing was
signing their name to an online petition
so we created an online petition I'm
sure we got a few thousand names and I'm
sure it had absolutely no effect and and
I think this is actually a very real
danger in the sort of online activism
space I am finally I've broken down I'm
on Facebook and every day five causes
come to me and ask me to join their
cause and joining their cause means
clicking the button that says join the
cause and then there's a list saying
that there are 10,000 people who joined
the cause now there are causes that I'm
part of but there are causes that I'm
part of because I actually put time and
thought and effort into them when you
make the barrier to participation that
low the value of that participation in
my opinion uh approaches zero very very
quickly let me let me quickly agree and
disagree with you um the where I would
disagree is that I think that the fact
that we have a higher degree of
granularity of participation that there
are causes which I can spend five
minutes on and others that I can spend
my life on is what makes the net and the
opportunities for civic participation
more pluralistic and more interesting
potentially than it is in in the you
know before you know and even in this is
not just a net thing this includes radio
and other things is my the fact that I
can call into that radio show or I can
go to jail for something I can have very
different and varying levels of
commitment that embed me in different
social groups that create a different
set of social belongings so I think that
is just important so I don't think it's
simply the fact that the granularity
participation is too low my concern
about e- participation and I where I
completely agree with you is I think
it's a well I'm on camera right I think
it's not um it's it's not one it's not
included in the examples in my slide
deck let me put it that way is because
again it's an example of a way of using
the net that's completely dis connected
from the actual institutions of decision
making it's again another example of
let's talk let's sign a petition let's
voice an opinion that has no opportunity
to go anywhere because there there is no
opportunity to get at information to
structure information to supply any
information in a useful way and to
provide it to either use it to do
something or to be useful to those who
need to make decisions so I think it's
just the wrong there's it's it's not a
clearly defined solution to a clearly
defined question if um you know there
are ways of soliciting Gathering opinion
of finding out what causes people
support and don't support I think it's
not necessarily the best designed it
just hasn't been designed or thought
through very well in ways that it could
be and where more can be done okay um I
probably should have been a bit more
specific when I said e petitions um what
I meant was the Eep petitions website
that maj's government runs so if in the
UK If you go on to 10 Downing Street you
can start a petition um and basically
anything that's got over 200 signatures
um the HMG has to respond
to I am actually speaking specifically
about the British example because
because that's the one that I know as
well and I think that you're talking to
that too there is some a kind of
response required but it's um you know
this is we've seen examples for you know
where congressmen got email addresses
that they started posting online or
political candidates have put a you know
ask the candidate um you know sort of
Link or email address and it's it's it
is creating the appearance of opening up
a dialogue but where in my view there
isn't the level of meaningful exchange
of information that's useful for either
side neither for the public because
they're being asked to do work that's
not really relevant to decision making
nor is it as useful as it could be to
those who are in government who are
making decisions whether they're in
government or other institutions or
Civic institutions um who really need
and are desperate for useful information
that goes beyond simply the asking of
people's opinion so in that sense you
know the sort of issue about the
deliberative ideal is one of the the
things I I wanted to mention is that we
have for so long thought frankly that
people are stupid and that the only
thing they're qualified to do is Express
opinions they're not actually qualified
to provide useful information what we're
seeing in the Arab Civic media is that
people are extraordinarily smart and
that we need to actually leverage the
intelligence that they have and the
information that they have not simply
the opinions that they have um which
frankly is much much harder to make
sense of in a complex world but okay go
over here thank you
um my name is Rick Burns and I'm working
on a a local news project here in
Cambridge um and my question is mainly
for Ethan I I it's pretty simple um why
why is that map a bad thing um I mean
you know why do we need to be involved
in the weeds of of um politics in
Madagascar and I mean I say that as
somebody who I mean I've I've been
overseas and and worked at you know done
reporting overseas and and it's
something I care about but you know we
have a lot of problems here in Boston so
I mean what is the why do we need to
know it's a terrific question it it's
the center question that I've been
wrestling with for the last four or five
years um the the sort of Rudy Giuliani
answer to it is is 911 um which is to
say the bridge blog say that no no no no
literally 911 and the reason for it is
um suddenly immediately after 911 there
was an enormous amount of interest in
Central Asia um people who had been
trying to sell a book on usbekistan for
the last 10 years suddenly found that
they had best sellers on their hands one
of the really interesting things about a
highly globalized world like the one
that we're living in is that our
physical security our Economic Security
our security of ideas any of this has
become interconnected to a degree that
it's never been before and so suddenly
something that seems completely
irrelevant um like politics in
usbekistan
suddenly becomes incredibly important
when it looks like we're in a global war
against people who appear to be camping
out in the fana Valley um in the same
way that you know anyone right now who
is looking at business opportunities and
isn't looking and trying to understand
what's going on in India or China or
Brazil or Russia is probably making
terrible areas and and I guess my
feeling on this is that as we get more
and more
interconnected a lot of these problems a
lot of these situations really demand
Global awareness one of the reasons I
picked Madagascar is that I actually
find it really hard to answer the
question of why you would care about
Madagascar my best guess in it right now
is that it's actually the most
biologically diverse Island on the
planet uh and actually has a level of
species diversity that we literally
don't see anywhere else and particularly
for people who are interested in the
Natural Sciences and discoveries of new
compounds and such it's actually quite a
fascinating place but this is the same
question people ask about the economist
this is the same question people ask
about why the New York Times continues
to put international news in that front
section my contention on all of this is
that we're actually doing ourselves a
tremendous disservice as we're
interconnecting our atoms we're making
it possible to get water from Fiji but
most of us know very very little about
Fijian politics uh those atams and those
bits and those memes cross over at a
certain point and we've let the atams go
much much further ahead than we've let
the mics go I would just uh uh in terms
of the center for civic media which is a
slightly you know different point which
is that um what we're trying to do is
develop uh and you know as I said game
new technologies so that they you know
help with Civic space help with Civic
Med you Civics rather than harm them um
but we're also trying to generate
knowledge about how that works and um
you know there's this famous uh uh
example of uh artificial intelligence
neural networks um uh where where the
dod was essentially trying to train
something that could recognize tanks and
um they they worked on a set of
photographs of like 200 photographs with
no tanks and 200 with tanks and uh they
trained the neural network so it could
perfectly differentiate between the two
and then they tried it in the field and
it absolutely didn't work and you know
it turns out that all the photos of the
tanks were taken on a cloudy day and all
the photos without tanks were taken on a
sunny day and that's actually what the
system learned to differentiate and you
know we run a risk as we develop these
Technologies if we just develop them in
you know Cambridge Side uh you know or
or Somerville um that uh that they won't
extend that that what we've come up with
is knowledge that works in a particular
venue but maybe isn't very generalizable
um so as we go through with this project
we're really going to be looking at very
specific communities working with very
specific Community groups and particular
locations and developing Technologies
for them but we're also going to be try
to understand and generalize you know
what are what are powerful and uh uh
consistent techniques and what only work
in specific areas and what can we learn
from
that
okay I think Ethan was the only one who
mentioned
corporations
and there's a problem when we talk about
consumers of
media as journalists tend to
do and not talk about
citizens there's another problem which
is talking
about Civics rather than the PO
but I'll leave you to reread Charles
olon to figure that one
out the Nexus of power within our
culture and our society and I think
probably increasingly in the world is
less with governments and more with
businesses and
corporations and addressing them with e
petitions or even demonstrations or even
legislation is a really
difficult
problem one of the things that's
happening now in the country is that
people feel that they are powerless and
they're right we have no
place for the edge of the
lever and I would suggest to you that
thinking about businesses and
corporations and structures of money
Finance legal systems things like that
has to to be looked at don't just
concentrate on governments local
Regional or
national I mean uh I mentioned
corporations too um
and what one of the major parts that
that I was talking about was that the
producers of of consumer Technologies
are producing things that are in their
own interests I literally said that so
um that is uh you know that is one
aspect of what I was saying and and you
know it's uh you're you're absolutely
right on many levels um uh the trick is
there are some really interesting
counter examples and one of them has to
do with these constructive technologies
that uh the questioner and a bunch of us
were talking about you know right now
when you go to a website there's a very
good chance it's being served by the
Apache server which is you know a
beautiful example of a um you know Civic
constructive uh collaborative project uh
that that essentially is bringing
Microsoft uh much less market share than
by by any means it should have um and
you know so what we're going to be doing
is looking at different interesting
prospects that allow communities to
serve themselves in the same way that
the open source Community has served
itself um but you know it's by no means
clear that uh uh that will work in every
situation um but uh but it's certainly
you know one of the very existing kind
of lanterns that were lighthouses that
we're looking at on the
horizon maybe since I'll just I'll just
say very quickly since I I think first
of all it's an important and well taken
point and in an effort to focus um you
know I want to talk about democracy in
the traditional sense but I absolutely
agree with you and there was a comment
there about governments are owned and
that's who I was referring to um this is
a very much more complicated question
than then you know who who is government
really if we want to you know you're
you're getting at the heart of that but
I think my um perhaps unfortunate attack
on the British Eep petition system is
answered by your comment and that the
fundamental problem with something like
an EP petitions or just putting out an
email address is that it doesn't really
get at any kind of institutional
change you know simply openness is not
by itself in changing CH you know is not
simply changing the institutions of
power it's not changing the way we make
decisions it's not fundamentally
bringing about openness in any new way
or really opening up that kind of Log
Jam in the way that I think your point
gets to and really signals the
importance of why we need to start doing
these things in all of our institutions
governmental corporate and at the Lial
space that goes across these different
things is trying to which is why my own
research and interest is on how we
connect up these things how we sort of
begin to do this um interestingly the
patent project that we've been doing is
a project that involves corporations
government and Phil philanthropies and
academic institutions and that's been a
very important part to My Mind of the
experiment that we've been engag engaged
in is looking up at how to open up this
community across those institutional
boundaries um as a way of bringing about
some kind of change in the process not
simply um not simply a you know more
voices or more opinions from right so
anyway it was an important comment thank
you okay over
here hi my name is Emily Lynn um I'm a
master student in the Technology
Innovation education program over at
Harvard go Harvard um
um so Ethan I actually I'm a Radcliff
fellow this year so I'm actually
there um working both sides despite our
institutional connection I actually take
issue with your um statement just deal
with it to your fellow bloggers who have
problems with the speed of
misinformation um spreading I know that
with that you were talking about a very
small fcet of the speed of information
basically dealing with misinformation
spreading and what do you do about that
um but with with relation to what Henry
showed with the car in the three
generations obviously again romanticized
but that doesn't happen now because my
grandfather has no idea what a computer
is you know and it just happens too fast
um so as far as substituting
participatory media for the deliberative
ideal implicit in the idea of
deliberation is also this idea of time
lapse and reflection and like what
happens to those people who are not in
this in the culture of as you put it
Ethan that's just how it is it's that's
how it is for a segment of the
population and is Civic media supposed
to be just for that
segment it's a great question and it's
what I get for giving a flip answer um
look
I that's how it is means we then have to
figure out the solutions to it an
example of how one might try to solve
this is a a project that we've been
working on for years over at burkman and
it it tries to deal with the phenomenon
of you try to have an online discussion
and someone is always the fastest to the
keyboard right so anyone says something
and the other person just jumps in and
gets another comment in there uh and
Jonathan zitra who's not only a
professor with us but is also a software
developer decided ah a heck with that
we're going to go in rounds and the way
that this class discussion is going to
happen is that everyone has the chance
to have one comment in a round that
round is closed we crank and then
everyone goes again and so it was a way
of sort of adding in a technical fix to
that sort of explosion of information
now I'll tell you that hasn't become a
real popular classroom discussion system
it hasn't gone out and sort of conquered
the world and I guess what I would say
is that within all of this these changes
happen and then we try over some period
of time to evolve our behavior and
figure out what to do with them most
people when they get on to email uh have
a certain number of very predictable
behaviors um they forward things all
over the place they use all caps they
reply very very fast to something they
don't consider it you'll always see
someone put up their first retract email
I'd like to retract this email there's
actually companies out there that try to
build retractable email by virtue of the
fact that they don't actually send you
text they send you an image so you can
take the image off the server later
forgetting that of course it's digital
and we can all make copies of it my my
point in all of this is just that you
know shift happens and then we try to
figure out how to cope with it I'm not
real happy about about the problem that
that chavea is talking about and I'm
dealing with it as well but I think
unfortunately there's no way to turn
this particular one back we have enough
people with enough devices that connect
quickly enough that as much as I'd love
to put a proposal in front of ietf to
slow every packet down by about half an
hour you know it's not going to happen
so that that's all I meant by it not to
dismiss the seriousness of the problem
but to make the argument that it's going
to have to be a social ad adaptation to
it but to get to the heart of what I
took to be your question about the the
transgenerational image that we were
talking about what we're talking about
is what I call the participation Gap it
is for for a long the last decade we've
focused on the digital divide which was
defined in technical terms in terms of
wiring the classroom wiring the library
ensuring everyone has access to
networked communication but the
participation Gap is about social skills
and cultural competencies in using those
Technologies to become a full
participant in the society and that requ
re Ires a different kind of educational
intervention a different kind of social
practice that enables that to take place
I'm very interested in that
transgenerational context uh you know
I've mentioned Jee burgess's work on
digital storytelling where she describes
young people going into Old Folks homes
working with senior citizens collecting
their old photographs collecting their
stories being facilitators that help
them learn how to construct that into a
different kind of representation that
can be passed on that can be shared as a
kind of ritual that that they work
together the young person maybe knows
the technology better the old person has
a different kind of knowledge that can
be passed on along that way and I the
analogy I often think about is the town
pageants of the 19th century where towns
where you had strong face-to-face
societies and continuities across
Generations the telling of the founding
of the town was staged year after year
by different generations of young people
and in the time towns that were relative
ly knew the people who were the founders
would or the family of the founders
would pass that knowledge on to the new
generation that were playing the parts
as were the older generation who played
the part 10 years ago have a different
have a connection to the young person
who's playing the part today so it's a
really actually turns out to be without
over romanticizing and a powerful
mechanism of creating exchange of
knowledge across generations and the
passing on of skills history local
context across generations and so I'm
hoping that one of the things the Civic
Media Center does is really take on this
question of how we reconnect young and
old and make that a central focus of how
we build Civic engagement in a new way
to help combat the participation Gap
problem as at least as it affects aging
Americans yes over
here hi Jean coup from the birkman
center um it sounds like there's some
agreement that uh here that the U
that you can measure the success of the
Civic media of Civic media by the
ability of the communities that use that
media to then access leevers of power
that they previously didn't have access
to and so I really appreciate the
framing of some of this discussion in in
terms of putam and then the shift from
looking at individuals to looking at
associations and associations at least
in American Pol Politics as a basis of
how we access power um corresponding to
that shift is I'm I'm curious if there's
also then a shift from looking at just
information which a lot of you have
talked about in terms of media and when
we think about media there's we often
think about the information that flows
back and forth to and Beth I think first
addressed it by with the word enthusiasm
um but ways in which groups come
together and form not just around
information but when you think about
Ethan's story about how getting
information out about well which police
car is carrying the dissident to the to
the jail there's also together with that
the willingness of people to actually go
to the streets now that they have the
information in their hands
um and and prevent that car from moving
forward at risk of probably their own
physical safety um or or Freedom so I'm
curious to what extent you see also
Civic media as as as not just simply
helping people share information across
with each other but also help building
that sense of group Identity or
enthusiasm or motivation to actually
act sure good um so thank thanks for the
question and and uh and Gan of course is
what he's being modest and not talking
about his own interesting work on
Virtual world's research and on bringing
technology to Bear to actually help
people to take action and to make sense
of their legal rights um and become more
effective participants and yes I think
it's exactly uh right is that one of the
things and it's why I took issue a
little bit with Ethan's comment about
the granular or what I took to be an
attack on the granularity of
participation is that one of the
wonderful things that the New Media
afford the opportunity to do virtual
worlds in particular is to make it
easier for us to come together and to
take action together about whatever it
is that we care about and I think the
interesting thing is and one of the ways
in which I would also I've moved away
from you have to understand that I'm
also was a very DieHard deliberative
Democrat I mean I've come you know I'm
sort of like experienced this conversion
that's ongoing so I feel need to confess
this constantly is about this
abandonment of this ideal or the
refashioning of this ideal is that these
ends no longer have to be purely
political political AKA dull and boring
um is that when we come together to do
things to share in a purposive ideal
whatever that may be including you know
make money build something talk about
something do something whatever it is
that we care about play a game in fact
um then it has these wonderful Civic
externalities social Civic externalities
more in the putam mesque sense but I
think it also has a profoundly political
sense in that as soon as we accomplish
something in the world together we're
powerful
um and that when we rethink we open up
the boundaries of what we Define to be
political power um we Encompass this
much broader SWAT of political media
which is why I think looking at the ways
in which three-dimensional interfaces
like Virtual Worlds enable us to engage
in Collective action something that
you've been doing um and enable us to be
powerful in whatever the ways that we
Define power so the the other other
point I would just add is that it's
about how we Define it for ourselves in
the groups and communities to which we
belong is what makes it fun
fundamentally interesting from a
democratic perspective and a First
Amendment perspective um because it
respects our values and our
goals I'm sorry that's the sound of
Second Life spilling
over um yeah I guess I would just yeah I
would I would make an argument that um
you you know the United States as as
Henry points out all the time is kind of
unique in in having an idea of uh um
local newspapers as opposed to kind of a
national but political paper several
vying political papers in in a country
I think that we we've got this idea of
Journalism and a kind of neutrality
that's embedded in journalism or kind of
disinterestedness which um makes when
you think about journalism or Civic
journalism it makes you think that that
disinterestedness has to to maintain but
you know one of the interesting things
that one of my students uh who's a
wikipedian brought to my attention was
just how uh stale um uh the wik news
side is they're they're doing something
like at most a few posts a day at this
point and the reason is because it's
impossible to write news from the
disinterest neutral point of view that
Wikipedia is you know supposed to be
using they can't come to any kind of
consensus about what's even a good story
um and you know so I think that one of
the one of the interesting things is we
we've shown that information doesn't
lead to action you know having knowledge
of your own situation doesn't you know
necessarily help and this John knight uh
quote that I had at the beginning thus
we speak we seek you know the KN Ritter
newspapers to bester the people into an
awareness of their own condition provide
inspiration for their thoughts and Rouse
them to their true interests it's that
rousing part um and and producing
technologies that will help them pursue
their true interest that is really
really critical in this equation I think
so and well we have been profoundly
uncivic and that the speakers occupied a
bit more than our time today and you got
less time because clearly there was a
lot of interest from the floor and
questions remaining we hope that
interest will motivate you to come back
to Future communication Forum events
this term uh there are several others
that are involved with some of the
questions we been discussing here
tonight and we'll continue with the
series in the spring uh in terms of the
the events we're going to host co-host
for the communication Forum through the
Civic media the MIT Center for future
Civic media so thanks everyone for
coming thanks to
[Applause]
Beth